[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous Bienvenue
c'est Science Publique votre rendez-vous
quotidien de débat de reportages et
d'expertise sur Public Sénat et voici le
sommaire de ce 29 juin la France
confrontée au risque d'un embrasement
généralisé de ces quartiers de banlieue
défavorisés la mise en examen pour
homicide volontaire et le placement en
détention provisoires du policier ayant
causé la mort de Naël non pas suffi à
calmer la colère 40 000 policiers et
gendarmes mobiliser ce soir dans 5000 en
région parisienne violence urbaine
usage des armes par les forces de
l'ordre défiance entre jeunes et police
politique de la ville beaucoup de thèmes
à aborder dans notre premier débat dans
une minute et puis pour notre second
thème on se demande comment lutter
contre ces feux hors normes qui
dépassent l'entendement
quand je dis qu'il dépasse l'entendement
c'est qu'il dépasse les 1 hectare et qui
forcément se retrouve sur des 10 20 30
100 hectares très rapidement et qui
dépasse ce que j'appelle des feux à
taille humaine c'est-à-dire qu'à un
moment donné ils prennent une telle
intensité une telle
intensité en matière de température
c'est des centrales nucléaires qui se
déplacent peut-on parler de mégafeux
comme au Canada vont-ils se multiplier
sous l'effet du réchauffement climatique
nos moyens sont-ils adaptés à ces
nouveaux risques alors que le Sénat a
voté ce jeudi une loi pour renforcer la
prévention des incendies on débat du
dispositif prévu pour cet été dans trois
quarts d'heure
mais d'abord retour sur une première
nuit de violence
urbaine qui a poussé le gouvernement à
réagir en urgence Flora sauvage plus de
6000 personnes ont participé à une
marche blanche cet après-midi à Nanterre
en mémoire de Naël 17 ans tué à bout
portant par un policier suite à un refus
d'obtempérer après-demi des meute la
crainte est grande au sein de l'exécutif
de voir la colère se propager si
mercredi Emmanuel Macron a dénoncé un
acte inexcusable de la part du policier
jeudi matin le chef de l'État a convoqué
en urgence une cellule de crise et a
condamné les scènes de violence ont été
marquées par
des scènes de violence contre
commissariat mais aussi des écoles des
mairies et donc au Fonds contre les
institutions et la République et
celle-ci sont absolument
injustifiable face au risque
d'embrasement l'exécutif tente d'apaiser
les esprits Elizabeth borne et ses
ministres se sont rendus sur plusieurs
points chauds des violences urbaines de
la nuit dernière de son côté le parquet
a demandé le placement en détention
provisoire du policier incriminé le
parquet considère que les conditions
légales d'usage de l'arme ne sont pas
réunis
par conséquent à l'issue de sa garde à
vue le policier mis en cause pour avoir
fait usage de son arme a été déchirée
aujourd'hui devant deux magistrats
instructeurs causes dans le cadre d'une
ouverture d'information judiciaire du
chef domicile volontaire
âgée de 38 ans le policier incriminé a
été présenté un juge et placé en
détention provisoire j'ai demandé au
préfet de police puisque le procureur de
la République a communiqué de suspendre
administrativement le policier qui est
en cause par cette affaire judiciaire
mais je veux aussi dire qu'il a le droit
évidemment comme tous les agents de la
police nationale comme tous les Français
la présomption de l'innocence le
ministre de l'Intérieur a annoncé le
quadruplement des effectifs de police
pour cette nuit la circulation des bus
et des tramways en Île-de-France sera
interrompu à partir de 21 heures
je présente tout de suite les invités de
ce premier débat Michel Aubouin bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes au fonctionnaire
ancien préfet essayiste auteur de ce
livre le défi d'être français à lire
paru aux éditions des princes de la cité
Nathalie sogone bonsoir bienvenue à vous
vous êtes journaliste éditorialiste à
l'opinion et puis deux de nos invités
sont avec nous en duplex ce soir
Jean-Pierre Mignard qui est avocat au
bureau de Paris mettre le conférence à
Sciences Po bonsoir maître Mignard et
puis également Philippe Rio le rio le
maire communiste de Grigny dans
l'Essonne merci d'avoir vous aussi
répondu à notre invitation et
j'accueille Laetitia cru pasitorialise
politique bonsoir Laetitia bienvenue à
vous je commence avec vous Jean-Pierre
Mignard je rappelle que vous avez
défendu les familles de victimes dans
plusieurs affaires emblématiques
notamment la mort de Zied et Bouna
c'était en 2005 qui avait provoqué on
s'en souvient trois semaines de
d'émeutes de violence urbaine est-ce que
vous craignez le même embrasement
généralisé ce soir
oui oui parce que les conditions ne sont
pas exactement les mêmes mais les
conditions sociales sont les mêmes
même si l'événement est lui-même
dramatique puisqu'il y a un reproche de
meurtre qui est fait un fonctionnaire de
police néanmoins les conditions sont pas
exactement les mêmes car le gouvernement
a réagi immédiatement en reconnaissant
de fait la responsabilité potentielle et
même plus que cela du policier sur la
considération des vidéos c'était tout à
fait différent pour les émeuts de
Villiers-le-Bel et puis celle de Clichy
quatre morts deux enfants morts d'un
côté les enfants morts de l'autre
toujours dans une confrontation avec des
policiers
et où on avait nié c'est-à-dire que les
pendant une semaine il y a eu d'une
course poursuite à Clichy qui a été miée
pendant une semaine alors que 17
fonctionnaires avaient été impliqués
directement ou indirectement ce qui
effectivement c'était le mensonge
qui heureusement d'ailleurs a été
dévoilé par les services d'inspection de
la police eux-mêmes heureusement et puis
un peu Villiers-le-Bel c'était la même
chose je précise que dans un premier cas
j'avais rencontré Nicolas Sarkozy qui
était ministre d'intérieur place Beauvau
et dans un deuxième cas il était devenu
président de la République m'a demandé
de venir avec les familles à l'Élysée
pour trouver une solution car on
craignait le soir même une émeute
beaucoup plus grave on parlait d'armes
et c'est pour ça que il avait décidé il
était président de la République avait
décidé de nommer un juge d'instruction
c'est d'ailleurs moi-même qu'il avait
chargé de l'annoncer dans la cour de
l'Elysée donc là le gouvernement n'a pas
la même position là tout de suite il dit
il y a une responsabilité puis je vois
d'ailleurs qu'un juge a été désigné tout
de suite pour Clichy il a fallu attendre
une semaine et payer pour être
effectivement plaignant est constitué
partie civile donc je pense que le
gouvernement a prial de la gravité de la
situation et décider d'aller vite pour
que le reproche ne lui soit pas fait
d'avoir voulu nier les
on y reviendra je vous redonnerai la
parole évidemment Jean-Pierre Miller
mais malgré tout vous nous dites que le
le risque existe parce que les
finalement le le climat social ou les
conditions sociales et sociétales sont
sont réunies oui Michel Aubouin ses
émeutes dont on parle dont on parlait
avec Jean-Pierre Miller c'était il y a
presque 18 ans est-ce que ça veut dire
que
rien n'a changé certains drame comme
celui de Nanterre peut provoquer que
c'est presque systématique les violences
urbaines à laquelle auxquelles on
assiste c'est presque systématique mais
c'est plus ancien que 2005 parce que
moi j'avais travaillé sur le surjet à
partir de 1995 dans le cas de l'Institut
d'autres études de sécurité intérieure
du ministère de l'Intérieur qui à
l'époque faisait encore des études et on
travaillait déjà sur les violences
urbaines la seule différence c'est le
contexte général qui a changé
c'est-à-dire qu'au début on avait des
violences urbaines avec des causes qui
qui étaient les mêmes qu'aujourd'hui
c'est à dire la mortalité la mort d'un
jeune mais c'est violent était
circonscrites à un parce qu'en fait il y
avait peu de liaisons entre les
quartiers et puis en 2005 on a vu
apparaître à cause de la généralisation
du téléphone portable la contagion à
l'ensemble des quartiers ce téléphone
servant par ailleurs toute une série
d'autres choses que téléphoner et enfin
et enfin cette fois-ci on a décontagents
encore plus rapide parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est pas le téléphone portable qui fait
la liaison c'est évidemment les réseaux
sociaux en particulier mais quand même
quand on se dit effectivement on aurait
pu remonter beaucoup plus loin dans des
épisodes de violences
urbaines donc ça fait des décennies que
personne c'est un collectif je dis il y
a une sorte d'échec collectif face à
cette situation les mêmes causes
produisent les mêmes effets oui les
mêmes causes produisent toujours les
effets puis en plus ça a été théorisé
c'est ça qui était assez étrange parce
que ça a été théorisé assez bien à
l'époque et moi j'avais écrit des choses
mais c'est surtout une sociale qui
s'appelle en général Angelina peralva
qui avait théorisé ça sur le thème des
violences de la mort c'est à dire en
fait les émeutes de la mort plus
exactement c'est à dire que dès qu'on a
une mort d'un jeune d'un jeune du groupe
des jeunes du quartier parce qu'il y a
dans le quartier il y a pas que les
jeunes en groupe il y a aussi d'autres
jeunes mais bon un mort de la mort d'un
de ces jeunes aussitôt l'émotion
populaire de ces jeunes
débouche sur des violences collectives
et ces systématique et même si la mort
n'est pas causée directement par la
police parce que dans l'imaginaire
collectif des quartiers de toute façon
dès qu'il se passe quelque chose c'est
forcément la police qui est coupable bon
là évidemment le lien est direct c'est
toujours cette émotion liée à la mort
d'un jeune qui déclenche et donc il
était évident qu'on aurait des émeutes
et il était évident que celle-ci prendra
une ampleur considérable de mon point de
vue d'ailleurs ça va pas s'arrêter
demain écoutez on le verra on espère
évidemment que ça puisse se calmer les
uns et les autres Nathalie ça goûte là
je vais vous entendre sur la première
réaction de d'Emmanuel Macron depuis
Marseille il était au dernier jour de
son de son triptyque marseillais et
quand il parle d'un je le cite un
inexplicable et inexcusable est-ce que
pour vous c'est quand même surprenant
d'entendre ça aussi vite ça rejoint ce
que nous disait Jean-Pierre Mignard dans
la bouche un président de la République
c'est concernant Emmanuel Macron et
concernant ce sujet là de la sécurité
c'est tout à fait inhabituel Emmanuel
Macron sur les questions de police de
sécurité il a depuis le début depuis son
élection
essayez de conserver en même temps c'est
compliqué sur les questions de sécurité
de de en même temps
de ménager la chèvre et le chou là il va
très loin c'est-à-dire qu'avant même
qu'on ait des conclusions de l'enquête
qu'on sache ce qui s'est passé
exactement on a simplement les vidéos
c'est vrai qu'elles sont elles sont très
parlantes mais il va très loin il donne
raison il est dans l'émotion d'abord ce
qui est très rare chez lui et il donne
quasiment raison
à l'émotion populaire est-ce qu'il le
fait aussi
en se disant ça peut ça peut apaiser et
limiter l'embras il appelle au calme il
le fait parce qu'il a peur il sait très
bien il anticipe les violences qui
peuvent découler et qui en ont
logiquement découlé déjà la veille au
soir c'est finalement c'est les
violences il aurait pu réagir le mardi
il réagit pas le mardi c'est à dire que
c'est quand même le mardi soir on a les
vidéos déjà on voit déjà que c'est un
dérapage que qui a de la violence
policière enfin et il ne réagit pas
c'est les émeutes dans la nuit qui le
font sortir du bois en quelque sorte et
donc c'est la crainte c'est la crainte
de l'embrasement d'ailleurs son
entourage le disait et c'est pourvu que
ça s'embrasse pas de nouveaux ce soir et
que ce soit pas encore et et
moi ma conviction c'est que c'est ça
d'abord qu'il fait réagir après je pense
que c'est pas anodin quand Mbappe tweet
j'ai mal à ma France
Omar Sy il est sensible à ça enfin c'est
des gens dont qui se veut
la jeunesse
lui-même quand il va
quand il va chez brut en 2020 il
reconnaît il dit le mot si ça vous fait
plaisir je peux parler de violence
policière c'est à dire que quand même il
est il est perméable à l'émotion de la
jeunesse
Philippe priot je me tourne vers vous
une première fois dans ce débat alors on
vous avait invité sur sur ce plateau
mais comme tous les maires de banlieue
parisienne que nous avons contacté et on
le comprend très bien vous avez préféré
rester dans votre ville c'est aussi je
trouve révélateur de cette tension qui
règne encore ce soir comment ça se passe
à Grigny qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
vous avez mis en place on a appris à il
y a quelques minutes que par exemple la
mairie de Clamart annonçait un
couvre-feu depuis ce soir jusqu'à lundi
matin vous êtes dans quel état d'esprit
dans un état d'esprit de responsabilité
envers nos concitoyens d'assurer
une tranquillité publique dans un
contexte
extrêmement difficile de révolte et donc
avec les services publics locaux avec le
tissu associatif qui est une composante
extrêmement importante avec nos réseaux
je pense
au moment des quartiers
nous essayons de faire en sorte qu'il
n'y ait pas
du pire dans cette période
instable incontrôlable et donc nous
travaillons depuis voilà d'arrache-pied
avec l'ensemble des services publics
locaux les associations pour que
le pire n'arrive pas donc voilà on est
mobilisé avec avec l'ensemble des
partenaires nous sommes des maires
casque bleu dans cette période des élus
locaux casques bleus ou on fait tantôt
mer pompier tantôt mermédiateur tantomer
pacificateur d'amener de la raison dans
une période où il n'y en a pas et en
même temps nous nous questionnons sur le
pourquoi de tout cela et vous si vous me
permettez quatre points sur les
premières interventions ce Thomas Hugh
vous avez dit que ce sont les banlieues
qui sont qui s'embrassent ce n'est pas
tout à fait exact il y a des villes pour
lesquelles il n'y a aucun quartier
politique de la ville aucun quartier
populaire pour lesquels il y a eu des
feux de poubelles des tirs de mortiers
et des arrestations dans des villes
dites bourgeoises ça c'est un fait
nouveau par rapport à 2005 maître
Mignard a eu raison de de dire que le
grand élément nouveau entre 2005 et
aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est cet outil là
les réseaux sociaux et nous avons eu
quasiment en direct
les images que nous n'avions pas eu dans
les périodes de 2005 et 2007 où
effectivement il y a eu de la
thermoiement on a essayé de cacher les
choses là ça explosé et je peux vous
assurer que ça circule de manière
extraordinaire
deuxième élément les conditions sociales
sont quand même différentes les
inégalités et l'injustice à explosé
entre 2005 et aujourd'hui j'en veux pour
preuve le taux de pauvreté dans une
ville comme Grigny qui aujourd'hui de
plus de 50%
ce n'était pas le cas en 2005
et Monsieur aubois qui a œuvré sur le
territoire et qui connaît bien ma ville
à découvert des situations sociales qui
sont bien pires que celles de 2005 donc
on a la poudrière le volcan était
nous vivons sur des volcans et des
poudrières et et parfois il y a des
éruptions à contrôler c'est le cas
aujourd'hui et je voudrais remercier
la justice certes la justice n'a pas une
baguette magique
pour faire face à l'apaisement
nécessaire et indispensable par contre
la justice a pris une décision très
claire aujourd'hui
elle ouvre une information judiciaire
sur
homicide volontaire
et détention provisoires c'était attendu
la justice a pris son temps on pensait
que les annonces allaient être plus
rapide mais elle a pris la décision
aujourd'hui et je trouve que la justice
est à saluer aujourd'hui c'est
extrêmement responsable dans la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes et
moi je tiens à la saluer je vous
donnerai la parole évidemment vous
restez avec nous pendant tous des bas à
la philipprio ce qui est visé lors de
ces émeuts de ses violences urbaines ce
sont des symboles de l'État ou des
collectivités locales on peut élargir un
petit peu c'est ce qui expliquait ce
matin sur France Inter la porte-parole
du ministère de l'Intérieur en écoute
Camille chaise
pour vous donner un exemple à Paris
il y a eu des tirs de mortiers contre la
brigade qui s'occupe des sans-abris qui
est une brigade de la préfecture de
police donc c'est pas seulement des
symboles de l'État c'est c'est vraiment
finalement tous les services publics
même ceux à destination des plus démunis
qui ont été touchées il faut pas
chercher forcément de symboles derrière
tout ça c'est vraiment des émeutes de la
violence
pour le ministre de l'intérieur avec ces
violences je le cite les professionnels
du désordre sont à l'oeuvre Jean-Pierre
Mignard je voudrais vous entendre sur
cette phrase de Gérald Darmanin les
professionnels du désordre sont à
l'heure est-ce que la colère qui
s'exprime j'anticipe un peu votre
réponse et seulement les professionnels
du désordre
non bien sûr puis d'abord qu'est-ce que
c'est que les professionnels du désordre
il y a effectivement des personnes et
même des personnalités qui portent un
regard sévère et des jugements très
critiques sur l'inaction des pouvoirs
publics depuis très longtemps Monsieur
le Préfet a raison c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose c'est que nous
savons très bien que nous avons laissé
s'installer avec le temps avec de
multiples politiques qui n'ont pas loin
de là de donner toujours le résultat
qu'on attendait des ghettos sociaux et
que une partie de la population
française donc les jeunes qui sont dans
ces quartiers sont si vous me le
permettez n'est pas rien
donc tout ce qui vient de là est
inquiétant tout ce qui vient de là
peut-être dangereux et notamment
lorsqu'il y a des questions de
confrontation avec les services de
l'État mais c'est surtout avec les
services de police et que ce soit juste
ou injuste la tentation est toujours de
montrer du doigt les parias et de donner
toujours raison a priori au service de
police je peux le comprendre les
policiers sont sous serment sont les
fonctionnaires de l'État mais en face on
a des jeux de gens dans beaucoup
d'ailleurs sont nos citoyens pour qui
de la population
une grande partie de la population
excusez-moi madame mais il y a un grand
parti politique en France s'appelle le
rassemblement national qui fait sa
campagne et ses fortunes sur cette
question je n'invente rien donc nous
avons même une structuration de notre
vie politique qui se fait sur ce sujet
deuxièmement il y a un certain nombre de
syndicats de police pas tous les
syndicats qui sont plutôt sur une
conception sécuritaire de leur travail
qui considèrent en effet que
dans les quartiers de la militarisation
interrompre parce que sinon plus
personne n'aura le temps de parler je
vous interrompre Jean-Pierre minière et
je vous redonnerai la parole sans faute
Michel Aubouin il y a quand même ce sont
des symboles de l'État qui sont qui sont
visés depuis de nuit et qui le seront
malheureusement sans doute encore cette
cette nuit des symboles de l'état des
symboles de la France comment vous
analysez ça moi j'ai pas de enfin je
pense pas qu'un message politique
derrière ça quoi pour fréquenter
beaucoup de ces jeunes et Philippe Riou
la rappeler tout à l'heure je vois pas
de message politique c'est pas l'état
qui vise c'est globalement tout ce qui
appartient aux institutions alors
évidemment le premier le premier de leur
adversaire c'est la police nationale et
ça depuis toujours pour différentes
raisons parce que et donc il s'en
prennent ensuite après la police il y a
les pompiers parce que les pompiers sont
uniformes et puis il y a tous les gens
qui rentrent dans le quartier parce
qu'après tout quand on n'est pas du
quartier on est un étranger et là ils
attaquent ce qui leur paraît être
les institutions mais en fait sans qui
est de raison particulière
jusqu'au point parce que quand même il y
a deux éléments nouveaux c'est les
mairies donc jusqu'à maintenant ce n'est
pas le cas on a eu beaucoup d'attaques
de commissariats par le passé mais c'est
pas le cas et puis on a pris un tribunal
alors ça c'est assez c'est nous oui mais
les écoles primaires de malheureusement
depuis le début c'est toujours comme ça
quoi donc on a toujours les écoles en
fait on a tous les éléments qui servent
aux jeunes ou qui ont servi aux jeunes
eux-mêmes et c'est pour ça qu'on a du
mal à trouver une rationalité moi je
pense que c'est l'émotion d'abord qu'il
est submerge avant les professionnels du
désordre je crois pas du tout ça parce
qu'il y a pas de il y a pas
d'organisateur il y a pas de il y a pas
d'organisateur mais il y a une
banalisation de la violence quand même
ah non mais il y a aujourd'hui une plus
grande violence qu'il y a 5 ans ou qu'il
y a 10 ans etc tous les indicateurs le
montrent donc il y a une plus grande
violence dans la société dans les
quartiers mettant la société en général
donc ça c'est c'est assez évident et
puis par ailleurs on a une nouvelle
parce que celle là c'est la génération
des enfants de ceux de 2005 quand même
et donc on a une génération nouvelle
plus plus aguerri plus plus violente
plus plus irrationnelle et organisé par
les réseaux sociaux et sans doute les
jeux sur les réseaux sociaux qui les met
tous en réseau donc ouais une génération
nouvelle alors vous parliez les uns et
les autres des évidemment de ces images
de qui tournent en boucle sur les les
médias sociaux les réseaux sociaux pour
l'avocat Henri Leclerc président
d'honneur de la Ligue des droits de
l'homme et elle finalement elles font
que ces violents urbaines sont
inéluctables on écoute c'était
inaluctable parce que cette mort donnée
représente une violence terrible et que
tous ces jeunes qui aujourd'hui se
soulèvent ont un sentiment de fraternité
avec celui qui a été tué et une
solidarité de corps je dirais de toute
la jeunesse de toute cette jeunesse
défavorisée qui dit on vient de tuer
l'un d'entre nous et donc il y a d'abord
un sentiment de
le chagrin mais il y a aussitôt un
sentiment de révolte qui qui n'est
inéluctablement on peut pas l'éviter
dans cette mort paraît brusquement sur
les écrans et pas réajuste
Rio cette solidarité de corps dont on
parle maître Leclerc est-ce qu'elle
s'exprime chez les jeunes de de Grigny
et puis au-delà de ça parce que
j'entends les les réactions des uns et
les autres mais
est-ce que elle justifie la violence
parce que tous les habitants de de ces
quartiers sont pas en train de mettre le
feu à des poubelles ou à des ou à des
autobus
il y a chez les jeunes et chez les
parents effectivement une une fraternité
lorsque l'on note la vie de manière
injuste à un enfant
et donc dans la dans le rassemblement de
cet après-midi des collègues élus y
étaient des responsables associatifs y
étaient et il y avait beaucoup d'adultes
qui disent stop à tout cela moi je crois
qu'il est temps que
le drame que nous vivons nous invite à
repenser la doctrine policière en France
c'est le sujet numéro un ne nous cachons
pas
la doctrine policière née de 2008 du
karcher est aujourd'hui au bout d'un
cycle nous devons avoir l'intelligence
collective et la force politique
d'apporter un nouveau débat sur quelle
doctrine de maintien de l'ordre qui est
d'ailleurs décrié on va en parler
nationale on va en reparler Philippe Rio
Pado pardon nous interromptes c'est
toujours un peu plus compliqué quand on
est en duplexe d'interrompre invité donc
je m'en excuse mais on voit pendant que
vous nous parlez les images de de cette
marche blanche à Nanterre qui était
aussi une marge de la révolte ce sont
les termes qui ont été employés par la
maman de de Naëlle et malheureusement
cette marche elle s'est terminée par
voilà des heures des des violences je
répète ma question tous les habitants de
vos quartiers de ces quartiers n'ont pas
envie de mettre les feux
du feu aux poubelles ou aux autobus je
je et vous nous dites vous nous dites
changeons la norme et l'usage de l'âme
par les policiers il y a aussi d'autres
questions qui se posent ce soir
peut-être mais moi ma réponse c'est de
vous dire que notre pays doit penser une
autre doctrine policière pour que cela
ne se reproduise plus et si vous voulez
m'entendre dire que dans les quartiers
populaires il y a des gens qui réfutent
cela et qui ont peur pour les enfants et
qui retiennent leurs enfants chez eux
parce qu'ils ont peur de cet embrasement
je vous le confirme monsieur il y a des
enfants qui ont peur de la situation il
y a des parents extrêmement mobilisés et
puis il y a des groupes qui à 15 16 17
18 19 20 ans
font ceux qui ce qui est en train de se
faire mais je vous confirme qu'hier
lorsque j'étais dans ma ville entre 10h
du soir et 2h du matin j'en ai rencontré
qui condamnait le fait que début soit
brûlé parce que ça pénalisé leurs
parents le matin et le soir certains
avaient peur que leurs écoles dans
lesquelles ils ont appris énormément de
choses pour lesquelles ils ont un
profond respect pour les enseignants
qu'ils ont rencontré
ils ne veulent pas que ça crame ils ne
veulent pas que leur gymnase dans
lesquels ils ont rentré ils ont
rencontré un éducateur ou une éducatrice
qui leur aidé à franchir les obstacles
de la vie ne brûle pas donc oui monsieur
ça existe mais on l'a toujours dit je
pense qu'une réalité un peu poussé à le
dire parce que sinon on a l'impression
que tout le monde est dans le même sac
et qu'on trouve des excuses à tout le
monde je pense pas qu'on puisse laisser
dire une une chose pareille bref je vois
que Jean-Pierre miniard me fait les
grands signes donc je vous donne la
parole une réponse une intervention
assez courte il y a encore beaucoup de
thèmes à aborder
je suis d'accord avec Monsieur Rio parce
que là nous avons une discussion alors
j'excuse sur Lyon qui est sur le terrain
même discussion de bourgeois tranquille
sur un splato très agréable avec des
gens qui s'écoutent et qui sont
plaisants vous savez la question de la
violence c'est pas qu'elle se justifie
c'est que c'est un fait social il est
réel c'est-à-dire que dans des
circonstances données un groupe social
composé de jeunes va réagir
inévitablement par la violence donc la
question monsieur ce n'est pas que la
violence soit justifiée c'est comment on
gouverne pour prévenir la violence bien
sûr et d'ailleurs c'est ce dont on va
parler tout de suite vous m'offrez la
transition idéale parce que Laetitia va
s'intéresser à la réaction de l'exécutif
et notamment à ce risque d'embrasement
généralisé puisqu'on en est là à
l'embrasement il a déjà eu lieu là on
parle d'un risque d'embrasement
généraliste juste avant de commencer mon
édito je dois préciser qu'on est tous
aujourd'hui sur un plateau ça ne veut
pas dire qu'on n'a pas aller sur le
terrain en banlieue faire de nombreux
reportages c'est pas très grave
qui a donné en fait le la de la
communication gouvernementale ce matin
dans un tweet aux alentours de 10 heures
alors il change de ton lui aussi après
avoir c'est vrai vous l'avez rappelé
Nathalie segun condamné les conditions
de la mort du jeune Naël cette fois il
condamne les violences qui ont été
perpétrées les nuits dernière dans les
quartiers des grandes villes de France
et il donne ouvertement son soutien aux
garant de la République regardez vous
allez comprendre regardez ce tweet et
les violences contre des commissariats
des écoles des mairies contre la
République sont injustifiables merci aux
policiers aux gendarmes aux
sapeurs-pompiers et aux élus mobilisés
le recueillement la justice et le calme
doivent guider les prochaines heures et
c'est exactement ce méta ce message de
la République attaquée qu'on va
retrouver ensuite dans la bouche des
ministres qui ont été déployés sur le
terrain le ministre de l'intérieur par
exemple Gérald Darmanin lui s'est rendu
à Tourcoing dans une école primaire
incendie et cette nuit et sans surprise
donc lui aussi on a appelé à la défense
de la République écouter
c'est pas la ville de Tourcoing qui va
reculer c'est c'est des voyous qui vont
reculer mais faire ça c'est dégueulasse
et puis c'est ça ça me touche
profondément
parce que parce qu'on voit bien que ceux
qui font ça
ils le font
sans doute pour atteindre le coeur de la
République le message est toujours le
même les mots sont après propres à
chaque ministre dégueulasse c'est
vraiment le vocabulaire de Gérald
Darmanin dans la lignée de Nicolas
Sarkozy par exemple dans le gouvernement
il y avait aussi il y avait aussi Éric
Dupond-Moretti qui s'est rendu dans la
prison de Fresnes qui a été attaquée
attaqué cette nuit le ministre de la
Justice a tenu à apporter son soutien au
personnel pénitentiaire qui était visé
cette nuit et il en a profité lui aussi
à son tour pour faire passer un message
à ceux qui selon lui toujours alimente
un climat Antipolis et antijustice on
l'écoute
qui est important c'est que le calme
revienne et je veux également redire
que certains irresponsables
depuis des mois
utilise des formules et des mots qui
tendent à discréditer la police et la
justice
et ils ont pour moi
une responsabilité morale dans ce qui
arrive aujourd'hui
dégrader une prison une mairie
commissariat de police un tribunal c'est
dégradé des lieux qui nous appartiennent
tous un mode communication politique
l'Elysée a choisi quel ministre aller
sur le terrain oui évidemment
Eric Dupond-Moretti Gérald Darmanin
était les premiers concernés en revanche
pour le reste du gouvernement alors ça
c'est une information off on dit c'est
un formel une consigne a été donnée
plutôt de réduire les déplacements
pourquoi pour ne pas surmobiliser les
forces de police et également pour ne
pas non plus trop se montrer trop
fanfaronné entre gros guillemets ne pas
donner le bâton pour se faire battre et
donc pour l'instant c'est plutôt mezzo
voce côté gouvernement pour la première
ministre et non alors il y a une grande
réflexion cette nuit je peux vous dire
que ça a beaucoup beaucoup réfléchi
entre Matignon et l'Élysée parce que
demain et prévu un comité
intermédiatériel à Chanteloup-les-Vignes
ou sur la politique de la ville et oui
autour d'Elizabeth borne dizaine de
ministres quand même avec la première
ministre donc ça a vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup cogiter là cette nuit est-ce
que oui ou non on maintient ce dép
comment est-ce que oui ou non le
contexte est favorable est-ce que oui ou
non c'est trop risqué et finalement il a
été décidé cet après-midi de maintenir
ce comité interministériel pourquoi
parce qu'il est nécessaire c'est le
communiquer qui le dit il est nécessaire
de pouvoir échanger sur les événements
actuels donc la première ministre va
prendre la parole et de présenter les
mesures que présente le gouvernement
merci beaucoup Laetitia Nathalie sogone
effectivement est-ce qu'on sait ce qui
peut est-ce qu'il peut y avoir des
annonces importantes demain
dans ce comité
le problème de
Monsieur le Maire a raison c'est à dire
qu'il y a quand même un problème de
doctrine de la police et que ce sujet là
en fait personne n'y a réfléchi depuis
le début du premier quinquennat on a
tous réfléchi on a fait des émissions
entières après le mouvement Black lives
matter aux États-Unis
les conditions
sur cette depuis l'abandon de la police
de proximité de plus en plus on est dans
une confrontation il y a une radicale il
y a la radicalité des jeunes qui s'est
renforcée mais il y a une politique qui
est uniquement basée sur la répression
dans les quartiers et donc ça ne peut
que être de plus en plus conflictuelle
et il y a jamais eu de réflexion au sein
de l'exécutif sur ces sujets là et à
chaque fois la politique d'Emmanuel
Macron a consisté à donner toujours plus
de moyens à la police qui en demande
toujours plus pour les rassurer mais
pourquoi parce que il y a quand même
quelque chose de fondamental c'est que
bon Macron essaie de tenir les deux
bouts de la chaîne mais les gilets
jaunes au moment de la crise des gilets
jaunes la police a été le dernier
rempart pour Emmanuel Macron il a eu
peur il a eu peur pour sa vie et ce
jour-là la police aurait mis larmes aux
pieds on ne sait pas ce qu'il en serait
devenu souvenez-vous des violences des
gilets jaunes quel est le chercher à
l'Elysée il a besoin de la police il a
encore eu après la réforme des retraites
il a eu besoin de la police pour pouvoir
aller dans les dans les
faire des rencontres des habitants sans
une protection policière il ne pouvait
pas souvenez-vous des casseroles donc
elle est il est pris en étau en quelque
sorte entre ce cette nécessité d'avoir
la police assez coté qui le protège qui
protège les institutions mais lui aussi
et son gouvernement et les critiques sur
le côté
répressif dictateur renforcé par le 49-3
etc et qui et là encore cet événement
apporte du moulin à ce discours il y a
une décision une action politique qui
est possible elle sera certainement pas
annoncé demain parce que ce sera pas le
lieu par la première mise mais c'est au
tour de la loi cazena la loi Cazeneuve
pardon de 2017 sur l'usage des armes par
les policiers et les gendarmes on en
parle beaucoup on a consacré une
chronique entière à ce thème hier dans
dans l'émission qui prévoit notamment
dans le cas d'usage des armes le refus
d'obtempérer à condition qu'un policier
agenda
soit mise en danger la première analyse
des images des vidéos hier nous nous
montrent qu'à priori les policiers
n'étaient pas en danger est-ce que pour
vous Michel Aubouin il faut revoir cette
loi parce que finalement elle elle donne
une espèce de blanc ça au policiers et
trop d'usage des armes par les policiers
les policiers ont obtenu ce droit parce
que les gendarmes l'avaient déjà et les
gendarmes ne l'ont jamais perdu
[Musique]
c'est assez difficile d'y répondre parce
que si en même temps c'est en fait assez
difficile de remettre en cause le rôle
de nos institutions de sécurité dans
notre société qui devient quand même de
plus en plus compliqué à gérer quoi il
faut faire très attention à ça qui est
des actes individuels
inappropriés c'est clair que la doctrine
en matière de maintien de l'ordre de
maintien de leur dont je parle pas de ce
qui s'est passé là et était à revoir
après le gilet jaune j'étais le premier
à le dire sur des plateaux donc je suis
d'accord dans le cas précis je il va
falloir réfléchir deux fois quand même
pour décider de nouveau des conditions
d'ouverture du feu parce que il arrive
aussi il faut pas l'oublier que des des
conducteurs sans permis roulent tombeau
ouvert dans des villes et finissent par
tuer des enfants ou des personnes âgées
ça arrive les cas où vous en connaissez
donc
si la police a aucun moyen d'intervenir
puisque toute façon les refuses tempérés
sont très nombreux ça va être assez
compliqué ensuite d'expliquer que ces
phénomènes sont naturels et que c'est de
la faute à pas de chance si on peut se
faire écraser par une voiture de ce type
quoi donc moi je pense qu'il faut il
faut comme y réfléchir beaucoup
s'empêche pas de réfléchir mais il faut
y réfléchir longuement Jean-Pierre
Mignard vous voulez réagir un mot
là-dessus
on vous entend pas
on a perdu le son est-ce qu'on peut le
récupérer Jean-Pierre minière sur le
l'usage
de revoir toute la loi mais c'est
notamment le cinquième alinéa le
quatrième alinéa qu'il faut revoir il y
a une phrase qui est totalement
incompréhensible alors si elle est
totalement incompréhensible je pense que
les policiers fonctionnaires doivent
avoir du mal eux-même à interpréter le
texte le texte il est fait pour les
aider à bien travailler et à ne pas
commettre des cas je vois et dont les
occupants sont susceptibles de perpétrer
dans la fuite des atteintes à leur vie
ou leur intégrité physique comme on peut
tout imaginer se servir d'une arme
contre des personnes pour les protéger
des atteintes à leur vie elles ont
intégrité physique c'est idiot donc on
le folie on voulait tirer dessus pour
les protéger d'une attein alors oublions
cette partie du texte je vois ou à celle
d'autrui je crois que c'est là que c'est
d'abord ou là on comprend très bien
qu'on peut faire usage d'une arme mais
il faut dire dans ce cas là que le
danger doit être imminent
il doit être évident et imminent voilà
c'est à dire que dans d'autres cas tant
pis on laisse filer la voiture on prend
l'identification et au tout tard on
retrouvera mais il faut effectivement
que ce soit que le cas soit réduit à la
protection d'autrui dommage imminent et
évident voilà ça ça peut aider en effet
les policiers à ne pas commettre ce type
d'acte et à protéger les gens et à
protéger des conducteurs qui le méritent
il nous reste 7 minutes dans ce débat et
je voudrais qu'on les consacre à la
politique de la ville et d'abord je
propose à terme traduit de nous
rejoindre on va on va parler de du
président de la République Emmanuel
Macron bonsoir quel est la relation
d'Emmanuel Macron on va dire au banlieue
depuis le début de son premier
quinquennat alors Emmanuel Macron et les
banlieues c'est au départ une histoire
qui semble bien partie retour au 16
novembre 2016 il est encore le jeune ex
ministre de l'économie que personne ne
voit élu et il choisit et bien la ville
de Bobigny en Seine-Saint-Denis pour
faire sa déclaration de candidature à
l'époque et bien le discours de candidat
d'Emmanuel Macron parle d'émancipation
parle de lutte contre l'assignation à
résidence un discours qui fait mouche en
banlieue Emmanuel Macron apparaît jeune
énergique il est populaire en banlieue
et il en joue par exemple avec cette
image
[Applaudissements]
un peu litigieux marquée à Sarcelles au
milieu des enfants du quartier qu'on
voit l'ovationné nous sommes en avril
2017 et l'image est tweetée par son
équipe de campagne et reflète la
popularité alors d'Emmanuel Macron et
l'espoir qu'il suscite qui sera douché
un an plus tard avec l'abandon du plan
Borlo 22 mai 2018 changement de décor on
est sous les ordres de l'Elysée et le
plan de Jean-Louis Borlo a droit à un
enterrement de première classe avec une
phrase polémique qui marquera les
esprits
quelque part ça n'aurait aucun sens que
deux mâles blancs ne vivant pas dans ces
quartiers s'échangent l'un à un rapport
et le disant on m'a remis un plan je
l'ai découvert c'est pas vrai ça marche
plus comme ça à l'époque Jean-Louis
Borlo qui a été l'auteur très en plus
tôt d'un grand plan banlieue sous
Jacques Chirac a été mandaté par
Emmanuel Macron au bout de plus de 6
mois de travail il remet un plan avec 19
mesures un budget de près de 50
milliards d'euros mais Emmanuel Macron
appliquera pas ce plan au grand dames
des maires de banlieue à la place il
préfère empiler les mesures les
dédoublements des classes de CP en rêve
plus la généralisation des emplois franc
la mise en place des quartiers de
conquêtes républicaine etc des mesures
concrètes mais pas de vision et surtout
pas d'affichage d'une grande ambition
pour les quartiers il y a un autre
indice le il y avait pas de ministre de
la Ville au début de son premier
quinquennat et pendant 18 mois début du
premier quinquennat la politique de la
ville n'a pas de ministère dédié à
l'étanglober dans le ministère de la
cohésion des territoires qui est porté
successivement par très éphémèrement par
Richard Ferrand puis par Jacques mesard
et puis c'est seulement le 16 octobre
2018 sous la pression des mers des
associations d'élus que Julien de
Normandie est nommé ministre chargé de
la ville et du Logement suivi par Nadia
et aujourd'hui cette Olivier Klein qui
porte ce sujet lui a été maire de
Clichy-sous-Bois pendant une dizaine
d'années c'est un vrai spécialiste des
quartiers il a lancé au mois de mars une
commission chargée du futur de la
politique de la ville et notez que
demain on va avoir lieu le comité
interministériel sur la politique de la
ville Elisabeth borne 10 ministre sont
attendus à Chanteloup-les-Vignes cette
ville qui en 2019 avait été le symbole
de la guerre des gangs après l'incendie
d'un chapiteau qui avait le surnom de
Chicago en Yvelines la première ministre
doit-il faire des annonces pour les
quartiers populaires en prenant en
compte le contexte de tension actuelle
merci alors je reviens vers vous
philipprio vous avez beaucoup réagi
pendant la chronique de de Tham ce
comité interministré est-ce que on peut
encore en attendre quelque chose après
l'abandon du plan Borloo en 2018
le plan Borlo et le fruit d'une
mobilisation et d'un appel l'appel de
Grigny où nous avons réuni plus de 1000
personnes des responsables associatifs
et tous les chéquiers politiques et nous
avons travaillé d'arrache-pied sur et
permettez-moi de donner le nom exact du
rapport Borloo vivre en grand
vivre ensemble la République pour une
réconciliation nationale c'est cette
ambition qui a été mis à la poubelle le
22 mai 2018
et pour rattraper le coup le
gouvernement a fait et c'est avec Jean
Castex à Grigny en janvier 2021 à comité
interministériel à la ville
co-construit avec les élus locaux et
avec les associations un peu à l'arrache
en période covid mais nous avions
co-construit aujourd'hui arrive un CIV
et moi pour moi les informations cela ne
se déroulera pas à Chanteloup-les-Vignes
mais plutôt à Matignon
et un deuxièmement la co-construction a
été extrêmement limitée et donc je ne
crois pas que ce CIV puisse permettre
sauf s'il ouvre de nouvelles
perspectives
l'autre dimension c'est à dire que la
force d'une nation c'est sa cohésion et
si on doit revoir la doctrine policière
en France on doit au voir revoir aussi
notre doctrine en matière de cohésion
sociale de manière forte puissante
durable agile avec celles et ceux qui
font la République tous les jours
c'est-à-dire aussi les gens de terrain
c'était ça le sens du rapport Borlo qui
est un rapport très collectif que nous
je crois nous devons retrouver en tout
cas dans sa vision et des dans son
ambition politique Michel Aubouin c'est
on l'a dit on l'a évoqué tout à l'heure
des plans banlieue on en a vu pas mal
quand même depuis depuis quelques
décennies pourquoi ça a jamais vraiment
marché d'après il y a pas eu assez de
moyens mis en œuvre ou alors une
question d'argent
donc on a eu beaucoup d'argent
simplement on a eu une longue enfin on a
à l'origine une petite erreur de
perspective qui est la question de
l'urbanisme parce que pendant longtemps
on a cru que tout ça était lié au type
de d'habitat de construction de détruire
les bars d'immeubles on a beaucoup
détruit à Grigny on a fait des choses
excellentes d'ailleurs on a beaucoup
rénové etc
ça suffit pas vraiment parce que ça
n'enlève pas les difficultés de la
population qui vit là même si même dans
cette très beaux immeubles à la Grande
Borne où je vais te de temps en temps
les choses
les immeubles sont très beaux et tous
des réussites sauf que les sont les
mêmes gens avec les mêmes difficultés et
par ailleurs depuis les quartiers se
sont multipliés les difficultés sur son
multipliées on a des difficultés
particulières aujourd'hui d'ailleurs le
président de la République a dit à
Marseille avec les copropriétés
dégradées donc Philippe Rio connaissait
par cœur parce que c'est lui c'est Agri
que se situe la plus grande que
propriété d'Europe et donc on a comme ça
toute une série de difficultés sociales
qui sont pas traitées attendent d'une
certaine façon donc la politique de la
ville est toujours un peu en retard par
rapport aux réalités sociales merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce à ce débat je rappelle Michel
Aubouin le titre de votre livre le défi
d'être français qui est donc publié au
presse de la cité merci encore et à
bientôt sur public